- Buckfast sounds serious.
- Like something you would
call someone you don't like.
- I kind of feel as though
it's really going to
fuck you up. Like really quickly.
(music playing)
- It looks really cheap.
- It's like a little monastery here.
- And it's made by monks,
so it's good for the soul and the body.
- Tonic wine. I don't
know even what that means.
- It feels like when they
came up with the label,
I don't know how long ago,
they just never changed it.
- High caffeine content.
Contains sulfites.
This sounds so healthy.
- So here we go.
That is not a nice color.
(gag)
- It's hard to relax my face after that.
(coughing)
- That was really thick
and like cough syrup-y
- It's cough syrup, mixed
with black carrot juice.
- It's not that bad
- I like this.
- I really like that.
That is like a really nice kind of port.
- It kind of tastes like Christmas,
like spices, and fruit cake.
- It tastes like bad sangria.
- You've got Jägermeister,
and you put, like, red wine in it.
Then let it out for like six days.
- The fact that it has caffeine in it,
I feel this would have
been the vodka Redbull
for 40 years ago.
- I didn't taste the caffeine,
but I definitely felt it.
- And it's the thing that's
going to kick you on,
until four or five in the morning.
- Is this legal?
- Very warming.
- It's kind of relaxing.
- I really like it.
- You can feel it going all
the way down your esophagus
and kind of just warming
up different parts of you.
- It kind of tastes like how
your grandma's house smells.
- I would drink that for breakfast
because it's refreshing and
it's got a bit of a kick to it.
- It's 15% alcohol and you
can't taste it in there
so that's like the perfect drink.
- I love this.
- I really want this in Australia.
It really smells bad though.
- If this is what the
Scottish take to drinking,
to get fucked up really quick,
cheers.
You're doing well.
- Team Buckfizz, bring it here.
Buckwhiz (laughing) What is it called?
Buckfast.
I got there in the end.
It's great. (laughing)